[Music]
from the studio that owns awesome heroes
like Batman and Superman comes a film
about the worst heroes ever and that's
from their actual trailer where to go
guys
you want us trailer yourself Suicide
Squad after the mixed reception to their
last movie Warner Brothers probably
regret spending just six weeks on the
script for this one now they have four
short pots to reshuffle their executives
juggle seven different cuts reshoot the
third act deliver on all the Joker stuff
they already put in the trailers and
manager director who takes shots at
their biggest competition it's like
there's some kind of what's the word
what we some kind of Suicide Squad man
this thing is writing itself with
Superman level threats on the rise
Amanda Waller has a solution she's
bringing together a bunch of bad guys to
save the world
this girl can do some pretty incredible
things from the bad guys she brought
together to save the world do you know
what [ __ ] they're high on attitude but
dangerously low on relevant skills like
a man who's half crocodile half racial
stereotype any other requests a guy who
shoots fire but Walt I'm gonna die in
peace before I raise my fist again one
chicken chop and exposition machine who
blurts out whatever the pod needs it to
here comes Slipknot the man can climb
anything put hearts out we can earn this
a drunk guy with a boomerang some Steven
Seagal lookin ass rope dork a 90-pound
girl with a bat sorry
a lady just kind of shows up and barely
says anything and has a magic sword
isn't even a bad guy why is she here
this is katana she's got my back I would
advise not getting killed by her her
sword traps the souls of its victims
that's good to know and Will Smith doing
everything he can to save this movie if
she can't cut it up graze start slipping
I need you white people that thing you
know I'll do oh yeah in a world of
flying man
monstrous this is the only way to
protect our country is it though you'll
love these good guys gone bad but
they're going up against bad guys who
are even better than the bad good guys
with bad bad guys like the putties from
Power Rangers with caviar all over their
faces Olmec from legends of the Hidden
Temple and The Enchantress an ancient
spirit released by the world's worst
archaeologist watch Cara Delevingne make
the jump from modeling to acting like
the wavy inflatable arm things outside
car dealerships actually formulates an
evil plot to destroy the world with wait
let me guess it's a sky beam isn't it
it's surrounded by rubble and a
disposable CGI army - right man this
really sounds like a job for the
Avengers or really any other movie in
the last 10 years but we know fans are
only here for one reason the Joker and
they're barely gonna get any of him
experience Jared Leto's intense method
acting that blurred the line between
actor character and total douchebag did
you send use condoms - Oh everybody as
he does in just 10 minutes of screen
time what no other actor has been able
to do make the Joker totally suck in an
interpretation that combines James
Franco and Spring Breakers with Ace
Ventura this handsome honk ah alright
and cat I think
it's so edgy you could cut him out of
the movie and it wouldn't make any
difference get ready for a film that
loves exposition almost as much as it
hates helicopters
as they literally spell out who the
characters are tell you how they're
feeling at all times
seems nice that is just a mean lady all
like you are evil and keep reminding you
who's good and who's bad the worst of
the worst
these are villains Amanda you noticed
these are criminals bad guys I'm the bad
guy
don't forget we're the bad guys we get
it
you all suck so gear up with a film
we all thought would put the DC extended
universe back on track but instead give
us two hours of characters trying to
look cool to a soundtrack that feels
like someone's scanning through a radio
dial with great performances by Will
Smith Margot Robbie and Jai Courtney of
all people that get canceled out by this
hula-hooping which and this manorexic
Juggalo but hey at least water woman
looks pretty good right
starring one-eyed Willie V Owens Davis
daddy's little cosplayer Keith lesser
that's not a noise dia de los Mentos to
Crockett or just the worst GI blows real
American zero this is Katara she's got
my back
I would advise not getting killed by her
her sword traps the souls of its victims
Vaughn gore man am I too soon I'm too
soon and what it felt like watching this
movie
The Boondock days oh no now all they
have left is the satellite that used to
film the other satellite be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers hey
screen junkies one even more Suicide
Squad in your lives then click the box
on the left to check out our extended
version of this honest trailer featuring
even more jokes all our alternate
starring names and absolutely no more
Joker that's a guarantee all uncut and
uncensored and while we have you click
the box in the right to check out our
upcoming roast of darth vader featuring
anakin skywalker getting burned again
the force will not be with him she just
told everyone your deepest darkest
secret you must be so embarrassed it's
the most expensive time of the year hi
i'm mr. meeseeks look at me M night
Shyamalan is a beautiful and majestic
man who I'm married to
and should make a movie about Jar Jar
Binks leading an army of minions deck
the halls with pepperoni stop telling me
what to say you fools